[Music]
so if you're new to connect connect is
an enterprise publishing platform for
static and dynamic content that you're
creating with our so that can include
documents presentations dashboards and
shiny applications and basically
anything that you're producing an AR it
is an on-premises application so you run
this on your own server behind a
firewall if you want and you're going to
host it you know on your own equipment
there
and the goal is really around sharing
data science artifacts that you produced
inside your organization so if this is
new to you I would recommend actually
that you check out the introductory
webinar that Bill referenced a moment
ago so we recorded this two weeks ago
the recording is available online as are
the slides and I recommend you start
there because we're going to be building
on some of the foundation that we laid a
couple weeks ago so if you are new to
connect you might want to start there
before you jump into some of these more
advanced topics but without any further
ado let's go ahead and stab into some of
the content that we want to cover today
so my goal for today is really just to
give you pointers to the different
tidbits that that I think are important
for you to know if you're going to be
managing our studio konnekt in a
production environment and so I won't go
into too much depth about a whole lot of
these but but really I just kind of want
to give you links and pointers to
different things that you might be
interested in if you are responsible for
managing a production environment with
our studio konnekt so pardon me if I'm
kind of flying through some of these
topics but feel free to ask questions
and we can come back and do a little
more detail and some of these things
later or you know just check out the
links once we post them online and and
you know hopefully you can you can kind
of find the information that you need
there with the links that I provide so
today I want to cover first of all user
management then secondly the management
of resources on the server and then
lastly we'll talk a little bit about
kind of the system management and system
security implications for the server so
let's dive into user management to get
started so we covered this a bit last
time so I won't belabor this but we have
three different user roles on the system
the first is an admin user who has all
privileges on the server and they can
access and kind of
manage anything that they need to but
irregular actions are audited and I'll
dive into what that means here in a
moment
below that there would be a publisher
who's someone that can upload or publish
content onto the server and then lastly
it is that viewer who is just a consumer
of content and can't offer content that
gets executed on the server so let's
talk a little bit about what the
experience of a connect administrator
looks like so first of all they have
access to special admin only actions and
so for instance this includes the admin
tab so if you're an admin on the user
you're able to access certain pages
within the dashboards that other users
aren't able to manage that shows you
things like metrics you're able to
manage users and things like that and
then lastly you're able to customize
some application settings that other
users aren't able to so you can define
vanity URLs for an application you can
customize the run as argument for an
application and I'll show you what all
this means here in just a moment but the
trick is that you don't get everything
for free as an admin and so some of
these things you're going to be able to
just hop on and start changing other
things you're going to actually have to
go out of your way to explicitly grant
yourselves permission to things that you
otherwise wouldn't have had permission
to do so let's I think that's probably
best covered by just an example so let's
let's look at an example of this so
first of all this is me logged in as an
admin user on connect
and so you can see here that first of
all I have this admin tab so that takes
me first and foremost to this metrics
page where I'm able to view information
about the CPU and RAM usage across the
server I also have an audit logs page
here where I can view kind of different
changes that have been taking place on
the server recently
and then lastly when I dive into
particular content even though this is
not authored by me this is offered by
someone else and I don't have particular
person's for for this content so for
instance here I can define a vanity URL
let's take a look at kind of a more rich
a document here so in this case we have
a schedule I as an administrator even
though I don't have special privileges
on this document I can go in and
customize the schedule for this content
I can you know define a vanity URL
change the run as user etc so I haven't
admin have free privileges to be able to
do some of these things however if you
look at something like a document here
that's private so here I'm logged in as
a different user this is the publisher
user and you can see that I for this
content here I've defined it to only be
visible to myself so this means that the
admin user should not freely have access
to the content this is sensitive content
that the admin shouldn't be able to see
and indeed if I go is the admin and I go
to look at that content this is the view
that I get so you can see that I'm still
able to manage the settings for that
content here but I do not have free
access to be able to view that content
and so this is kind of what we're
talking about when we say the admin has
the privileges to do whatever they need
to do on the server but they don't get
everything for free so I am NOT able to
view this content although I can go in
and I can add myself as a publisher or
the viewer because I'm able to manage
the settings on this conte and at that
point I would be able to view the
content and so the trick here is that
all of this though is managed when you
make these explicit actions to add or
remove yourself to a particular bit of
content all of those actions are going
to be captured in the audit log that I
referenced earlier so when I go look at
the auto lunk you can see here that the
admin user assigned themselves as an
owner as a collaborator on this app and
then they were moved in tells us an
owner is a collaborator on top so now
while I am able to do everything and
navigate
whenever I need to cover to be able to
manage the server anytime I take those
explicit options of kind of going out of
my way to take special privileges on an
application that's going to be captured
in the audit log and that's kind of the
balance that we try to strike here with
an admin lastly if you've missed this
and our latest release the 1.44 one
release we also do have the ability to
download the source code for for content
and again that's only available to users
that are that are explicitly granted
collaborator privileges so I as an admin
do not get free access to source code
published on the server however if I add
myself as a collaborator than I am able
to download the source code for an
application so this is kind of the
balance that we tried to strike with an
admin but I think it's important if
you're going to be managing a connect
server in production that you kind of
understand what the privileges of an app
then actually encapsulate and what you
get for free and what you don't so next
we'll just kind of move on and a lot of
these things I'm just going to cover in
rapid-fire but the next one that I
wanted to cover is the default user role
so this is the setting that's managed in
the authorization section and then the
default user role setting and this is
basically the role that fresh users
should take when they sign onto the
server
the default right now is publisher which
means that when a user signs up on your
server or when they you know login using
whatever authentication protocol you're
using that user is going to become a
publisher on the server they're going to
have access to publish new source code
if you want to change that if you want
to limit that so that default so that
new users coming into the server are
just viewers you can change this
configuration setting here and make that
a viewer and this is actually subject to
change we've considered actually making
the default viewer and so in which case
if you wanted to default to be publisher
you could of course override that here
another tool that you should be aware of
if you're managing Connect is the user
manager command-line interface and this
is a root only command-line interface
that allows you to interact with Connect
in kind of a batch way and so right now
there's kind of a limited subset of what
you can do with this command but we
envision this growing over time to
capture more of the interactions you
might want to take within Connect so
right now one restriction is that the
server actually does need to be stopped
in order for you for you to use the
command-line interface here and that's a
restriction that may be listed here in
the coming month but right now you can
access the tool at this location opt our
studio Connect bin user manager and then
you can run commands such as lists to
list all the users in the server you run
alter to change a user for instance
promoting a viewer to a publisher or
promoting a publisher to an admin user
and you can also actually dump the audit
logs even in the CSV format here so if
you wanted to navigate and browse the
audit logs on your own time and/or using
your own tooling you could do that here
I'm using this user manager tool so
something you should be aware of and you
can view all the documents in the admin
guide for what different inputs are
available in this command next there's
an idea of user locking in the server
that you should be familiar with so so
as at the time of this recording in
early 2017 we don't have a notion of
user deletion and the reason for that is
that there are a lot of open questions
around what should you do with a user
who's deleted what should you do with
their content so you migrate it to
another user should you keep it alive on
the server or should you get rid of it
so until we settle some of those
questions right now we've kind of set
alone this compromise that user locking
so if you for instance have an employee
leave the company and you don't want
them to have access to the server
anymore you can lock their account which
forbids any further login or interaction
on the system they can't publish updates
or new content to the server and they
also don't count against your license so
they're not going to count as a as a
named user then I can pick up the seed
for your license when they're locked and
also you should be aware that you can
rename users and so if your goal is just
to get rid of a user who's taking up a
username that you want you can certainly
just change the user name for that user
and lock it and then create a new user
account with the username that you
desire so that's a bit about user
management and we can transition into
resource management now which is a bit
more of a complex topic so one of the
most common questions that we get around
Connect is the idea of resource
budgeting or how large should my server
be and the problem or the difficulty in
answering this question is that the the
requirements here almost depend entirely
on what your users are deploying so if
you just have a couple of simple
documents that you know a couple of
simple dashboards that are updated once
a day that people are going to access on
your connect server you could probably
get away with some running this on you
know something like very very small even
you know raspberry pi could probably
handle that kind of workload however if
you're doing you know very intensive
shiny applications that are doing you
know genomic analysis on multiple
gigabytes of data
then your server requirements are going
to be much much larger so ideally if you
if you have the luxury of being in a
virtualized environment where you can
kind of scale up or down the server that
would probably be your best bet but
otherwise if not you can kind of run a
proof of concept and see what the
hardware requirements are given the
applications and the types of work that
your that your users are publishing to
the server and that's really the best
way to kind of get a feel for what your
requirements should be in terms of
hardware for the server so in terms of
the philosophy of Connect on demand
requests are largely what we're
servicing when requests are coming in
and those are just going to be serviced
best effort so you know as a request
comes in for a shiny application we're
going to do our best to spin up that's
what that shiny application hope that
there's enough memory available on the
server so but there are some knobs and
some tuning that you can do to cap the
resource requirements available to
particular applications or different
different use cases so first of all the
around shiny there's there's a notion of
shiny scaling so you can scale shiny
applications and connect to multiple
processes so if you're not aware are a
single threaded and connect can actually
load balanced a particular application
across multiple independent arm
processes running that at that same
application and so this is what's
managed here in the performance tab on
the shiny app so as an admin you can go
in and you can override a particular
performance settings for an application
and set for instance the number of max
processes how many processes you know
under the heaviest load that you might
be willing to run for this application
and then down at the bottom here you can
see kind of some of the scaling
parameters around how many connections
should be supported for process and then
the load factor is basically how quickly
do you want to ramp up from the minimum
number of processes to the maximum
number of processes as load increases
the minimum number of processes as the
name implies is the is going to
guarantee that in processes are running
for this application at all times the
right answer for this for almost all
applications is 0 however if you have an
application that takes a really long
time to start up and you don't want to
use are hitting it having to wait
multiple seconds or even minutes for the
shiny application to come online you
might want to defined this as one or
even two to ensure that that there's
always a process available for incoming
users you can actually cap this if you
find that users
kind of you know setting absurd minimum
process values you can actually cap this
using the scheduler dump in process
limit setting and that will allow you to
say no application should ever define a
min process that's greater than X and so
that gives you some control there next
we've got a notion of shiny timeouts and
so this currently is a globe these are
global settings eventually we envision
that these will be customizable by the
application but these two find two
different parameters so first of all
this defines the maximum amount of time
that you would want to wait on an
application to start in the default is
60 seconds which means that if a shiny
application takes longer than 60 seconds
to start and come online we're going to
assume that the process is having some
problems and we're going to give up
waiting on it if you find that you're
building shiny applications that indeed
genuinely take longer than 60 seconds to
start you can increase this limit to say
you know wait on that process a little
longer the second value here is the
minimum time that we should keep a
worker process alive after it goes idle
so what this means is that after the
last user leaves process after they
disconnect and the process is now empty
and not serving any shiny sessions we're
going to wait five seconds and if no new
traffic comes in then we're going to
reap that process that's a pretty
reasonable default for for average
workloads but again if you're running
these very large processes that take a
lot of time or take a lot of resources
to startup you might not want to reap
the process that quickly you may want to
leave it open for multiple minutes or
hours or even overnight so that you
don't have to shutdown and spin up these
processes which might be an expensive
operation next we're stepping away from
shiny and more into the notion of
scheduled reports we do have a throttle
around report concurrency in the latest
version of our studio konnekt
so this is a - an application stopped
scheduled concurrency and this allows
you to determine the number of
concurrent scheduled reports that you
would ever want to run in parallel and
they by default this is set to two and
so if you have 20 users who all set up
their documents to run every night at
midnight rather than trying to run all
20 of those reports at one moment which
you know might cause some some resource
contention or even some stability
problems on the server we're only going
to run two at a time and we'll just
iterate through as quickly as we can to
get all 20 reports executed as close to
midnight as possible so
you find that you have more capacities
than than to you can certainly up this
limit to have multiple processes running
at the same moment or likewise if you
need to tune that down you can the next
notion of resources that you might want
to manage is around the disk and so
there are a few different things that
we're going to store on disk so most
obviously we're hosting the applications
that your users are sending us and so
first and foremost we're going to be
storing on disk the content that your
users upload to us we call these bundles
but these are basically the application
in any Associated data or metadata
that's associated with those
applications that the user is going to
give us and we store those in a
compressed format and basically we're
storing the exact blob that the user has
uploaded to us originally we're going to
we're going to keep that retain that so
that you always have a copy of kind of
what the user originally gave us next in
order to actually run the application we
obviously need to unzip those bundles
and have them in a directory where we
can actually start executing that code
so you will have one copy of each
application that's actually laid out in
an unzip folder where we can actually go
have our run that code and access the
data associated with it if there is some
next there's a notion of a packrat cache
and we talked about this in the last
webinar but we use a system a packrat to
manage to kind of recreate the
environment in terms of the are packages
that are available on the publishing
environment or the you know the IDE that
your that your customer that your pub
that your user is using excuse me we try
to recreate that environment on the
server using this packrat system and so
what that means is that every time that
a user publishes some code if they have
a particular version of a particular
package we're going to compile that and
store it on the server as well so you're
going to have one copy of each version
of each package and that is specific to
the are version so if you support
multiple versions which we'll discuss
here in a moment then you might have
multiple copies unique PD jar version
however that being says all of these are
shared in the same library or same cache
instead that means if you have multiple
users who have published the same
version of ggplot2 using the same
version of are you're not going to be
storing those copies redundantly they're
all going to be pointing to the same
singular copy of that package so we're
not we're not storing any extra or
wasted copies there
but you will need to kind of budget for
these next we sorts of metrics these are
usually a pretty small usage of of the
disk base but you know for instance you
saw the RAM and CPU usage that gets
stored on disk and then lastly we store
the information around our processes
that have executed in the past the logs
associated with them I wouldn't expect
that you'd ever see any disk concerns
here unless you have a user who's you
know dumping multiple kilobytes of data
to the log each time somebody touches
the slider on the shiny application or
something absurd like that but generally
this is a pretty small consideration in
terms of disk so this is just one
snapshot of what are the beta our studio
konnekt server looks like right now and
so you can see here that we have over
2000 applications or 2000 bits of
content that have been published to the
server and we really do almost no
policing on the server in terms of the
bundles that are uploaded and so if you
look into this in a little bit more
detail it turns out that there are a
couple of applications in particular
that have multiple gigabytes of data
associated with them which really blows
up the the bundles and the unzipped
package size and so I would expect that
on a server that's actually you know if
you're concerned about this cuse agenda
please this little more tightly I
suspect that you'd be able to drive this
down even for a server that has lots of
applications but you can see here that
for 2,000 bits of content we have 85
gigabytes of disk usage and you can kind
of see kind of the ratios here of where
that disk usage is coming from so in
terms of managing the disk usage and
kind of putting a capacity around what
you want to store there are a couple of
knobs that you can tune here so the
first one is around bundle retention and
this allows you to throttle the number
of bundles that are going to be retained
for each application and so as you saw
as I as I previewed here a moment ago
in our CTO Connect 1.41 we now have the
notion of being able to rollback an
application to a previous version or
roll forward to a more recent version
and that is all predicated on the idea
that that your old bundles are still
alive on disk and that you haven't read
them and so by default we actually
retain all bundles forever and that
might not be what you actually want you
may say that having you know five copies
of an application is plenty in any
version older than five versions ago you
can go ahead and delete and if that's
the case then you can just customize the
setting here to set that to a different
value other than zero
and at that point we'll we'll start
deleting those those older bundles off
of disk really here though you may find
more useful than actually configuring
the setting just the idea of introducing
a policy which basically just says asks
your users not to publish very large
sets of data alongside their
applications and so this is really where
large bundles come from is if you have
you know a 4 gigabyte CSV file that
you're wanting to analyze and some are
mark our markdown document the naive
thing to do would be to bundle that for
gigabyte CSV file alongside your our
markdown code publish that all as a
single bundle which now means that every
time that you update your our markdown
code your republish nginga bytes of data
which is going to consume a lot more
disk space than you really need because
your disk because your data presumably
is not being version alongside the code
that's actually analyzing that data and
so as a best practice you should really
probably provision your data separately
on the server and then just publish only
the source code that's going to analyze
that data and so if you push this data
somewhere on the server and you make it
available in a kind of global directory
where users can access it now you'd be
able to have the source code X you know
only publish the source code in the
bundle that would access that data
rather than having a redundant we
publish the data every time you you make
a change to your source next and I won't
belabor this one because it's a usually
a pretty small consume consumption of
disk space but we do have throttles
around how many jobs we're going to
retain or how many process the process
information that we're gonna retain so
by default we say we're going to keep up
to a hundred processes associated with
each application and as soon as we have
more than hundred processes the oldest
ones are going to start getting deleted
and likewise any process with older than
thirty days we're going to start
deleting off at this so as soon as
either of these constraints is violated
the job is going to be deleted from disk
we won't have the process logs
associated with that anymore if you're
an environment that's highly audited and
you need to make sure that you have you
know the logs associated eternally you
can customize these settings to keep
older copies of jobs or more copies of
jobs for each application so kind of
larger picture than a few things that
you should consider from an IT
perspective so first of all you can
manage the server data setting which by
default is going to be viral of our
studio konnekt that's where we're going
to
our variable size data associated with
connect if you have an NFS share or
something larger where you want kind of
the bulky data stored for connect you
can customize that setting and put it
will put all the data there so in
reality if you can keep the bundle sizes
small the disk usage should be probably
under 100 Giga bytes for a for a kind of
medium traffic server if you're
expecting that you're dealing with large
data sets and people are going to be
publishing a large bundles you might
want more than that but obviously if you
have the luxury as being an environment
where you can have kind of a scalable
disk volume that would be the most ideal
but you're going to get the best
performance out of a fast disk so
something like SSD is usually
appropriate for for the kind of
workloads that we're using here
and NFS should be fine although you
should consider performance make sure
that the perform at work share and do be
aware that the sequel Lite database
which can be pulled out separately from
from this data directory must be on
local disk that cannot be on NFS so
that's everything other than the sequel
Lite database can be shared in in NFS
can we discuss that a bit in the last
webinar so I won't go into more detail
there if you well sorry when you want to
run backups for our studio konnekt you
know you can certainly use a snap
shopping system if you have you know
that luxury on your on your disk volumes
if you don't have snapshotting then and
you actually want to run a manual backup
then here are a couple directories that
you should consider including in your
backups so first of all obviously the
VAR lobe our particular connect
directory which is going to have all the
all the data that we referenced earlier
on bundles and applications and process
logs cetera and you should also consider
including Etsy our studio connect this
is going to include your config file and
then some other peripheral files that
might be used to manage the server and
then of course if you pulled your
database out because of you know NFS
concerns or anything like that then be
sure that you backup your database as
well in order to do this you do need to
to bring the server offline run the
backup in order to get a consistent
backup and then you can restart the
server there if you are unaware we do
support multiple versions of our by
default is we're going to add startup
we're going to scan the most common
locations for our and also look at the
path to try to find the versions of our
that you have provisioned on the server
if they're not in the most common
locations or if you have our and kind of
system directory you can register this
as explicit our locations wherever they
are on your server and all of this is
documented in the admin guide at the
link that I reference below and now
what's going to happen then is every
time that a user publishes you're going
to we're going to do our best to align
the version of our that they are using
to the version of our that to the
versions of our that you have available
on the server and there are a few
different alignment algorithms that we
have available all of which are again
are described in this link here that I
mentioned there and so that would define
kind of how we go from the client
version of our that they're using to
find the appropriate server version of
our that you would want to use to
associate with that another feature that
you should be aware of is the notion of
process supervisor and so this is
basically a prefix that will provide
into the our process invocation this is
to find an application set supervisor
and for instance we provide the example
here running nice which is a linux
command to run familiar that allows you
to kind of set the process priority for
a given application and so this is a
prefix that we're going to run before
spawning our he says in this case we're
going to say give the nice priority
level 2 and then invoke our if for
instance you have a shell script that
needs to be run before running our in
order to provision certain resources on
the server you could use this to kind of
define a custom shell script that's
going to run before running our and
there's some caveats around how you
should invoke this and how it canapes to
behave but all this is documented at the
leak that I provide here so if you're in
a world where you do need to provision
certain resources before spawning are
this maybe is that's interest to you
secondly this edition of customize are
run as a user so so our CPU connect has
a certain user that we're going to
invoke are as so are the connect server
itself is going to run this route but we
don't respond are as route so we're
going to spawn are as the user our
studio connect by default which is user
that gets created when you're on the
Installer and the primary group for that
user is the rstudio connect group and
all of this is described in more detail
at this link but you can actually go in
and start customizing that and so if you
define globally a new application start
run as user you can say I don't want to
run rsz our studio connect user by
default I want to run into someone else
and that's totally fine you can change
that globe
you can also change that per application
and so this is configured in the
dashboard and you do have to have admin
privileges in order to change the
settings so only an admin can modify the
setting but basically this allows you to
go in inside the dashboard to a
particular application and say rather
than running as a default user which
again by default it's our studio konnekt
rather than running is that user I want
to run as a different user on the server
and so for this particular process
you can have it execute as a different
user on the server and that allows you
to make special system resources that
may be available on these particular
users available to certain applications
and so perhaps globally you want all
your processes to run as our studio
konnekt user but there may be certain
applications that require special access
to disk resources if you're following
that pattern of provisioning data on the
server before you know separate from the
bundle perhaps you want to actually
customize and segment off certain data
sets and say only certain applications
should have access to them you can do
this using the standard Linux file
permissions and then you can just have
the are applications that should have
access to that data sets run as a
certain user who would have access to
them on the server so that's certainly a
feature that you should consider and be
aware of if you're in the world of
trying to customize access to particular
system resources based on individual are
applications then do be aware that the
any user that you specify does have to
be a member of the primary group of the
default runners user which again is the
art studio konnekt group so you can't
just go in and specify any UNIX user on
the system and have them start invoking
are you would actually need to make sure
that those users are members of the
Archaea connects group before they would
be eligible or they would be candidates
to execute our through our studio
connect you can actually take this one
step further by enabling another setting
which is applications that run as
current user and now this does require
pay off indication and it defaults to
false which is disabled
but if you go in and you disable the
setting in you're using Pam then what
that actually means is that you could
have a shiny application that rather
than running as a hard-coded user or
even a custom hard-coded user this the
shiny application will actually run as
the user who is viewing the application
and so again if you know this does
require pain
because that means that the user you
know the user has already logged into
the system we know that their username
is a valid linux account on the server
and so we can actually go out now and
start running the our process as them
which means that your shiny application
you know for instance if you're if
you're in like a Kerberos environment or
something like that where you have
particular resources that are available
to every user on the system and you want
to know that the our processes are the
shiny interactions that they're having
are actually based on the our process is
running specifically as that user then
this is a way to accomplish that and all
of this again is documented in the admin
guide at this link here that I provide
we also do support Pam sessions and so
if you want to use Pam to kind of
provision additional resources before
spawning are you can specify a custom
Pam service and more documentation so
they live on the app and get there all
right so then moving out of the last
section here around system security and
kind of some of the considerations that
you should be available that you should
be aware of from a security standpoint
so first of all as I suspect most of us
know HTTPS is very important and so if
you are accepting usernames and
passwords through your system then then
you should almost certainly be using TLS
encryption or err HTTPS and so this is
pretty simple to define you just set up
the HTTPS section you set up the listen
and the key and the certificate settings
to define what port and what certificate
and what key you want to use for HTTPS
you can also set up the HTTP redirect
which will say for instance if you want
to listen on port 80 for HTTP request
and forward them on to HTTPS then this
is a way that allows you to do that all
self-contained within the server and
this is something that you should really
pretty strongly consider especially if
you're if you're accepting usernames and
passwords another thing that you can
consider here are on security
implications would be the notion of
browser security and so there are a few
different options that you can configure
all of which are documented in more
detail at the link that I provide here
but we do support HSTs
we have content type sniffing
customization you can change the X frame
options and you can even define custom
HTTP headers that you want included on
all requests that are going out of the
server and the best way to kind of
verify that you've got some of these
settings available is SSL labs provides
a great tool and if you go to this link
here you can actually point this at your
server
assuming that it's public you can point
this at your server and it'll run a
suite of tests against first of all your
SSL certificate but also it'll kind of
confirm that that you have all of these
settings set appropriately and that your
server is appropriately locked down I
alluded to this earlier but we do
support audit logs and so this is
something that you can monitor if you're
interested in kind of staying up to date
with the system changes and the
interactions that users are taking on
the server you know this is something
that you should definitely keep an eye
on and if you want to do this in a more
automated way or kind of in a more
customized way you can certainly
consider dumping these to CSV using the
user manager tool and then inspecting
them using your own toilet
one other question that we get often is
the idea of kind of separating staging
from production and this is something
that is now supported and connected now
that we support the idea of exporting a
bundle so the best way to accomplish
this now and this is something that we
do want to improve in the future but the
best way to accomplish this now would be
to run two different connect servers one
of which can be kind of your staging
environment where people can sort of
publish content that they're they're
still working on and then you know once
it gets q8 and once you're actually
happy and comfortable with the content
you can export that bundle and then
republish it to a production environment
and that will allow you to kind of
separate the staging from the production
environment if you're concerned about
resource contention between you know the
staging environment in the production
environment this is kind of the best way
to sort of wall off those two things and
to accomplish them one of the features
that you should be aware that's kind of
nice if you're going to be managing this
we do support two different settings
that allow you to provide just messaging
for users and so the server dot public
warning is going to provide a custom
HTML warning on the unauthenticated
landing page so when people visit
connect and they're not logged in
they'll see this public warning and then
for logged in users you can define the
logged in warning setting and that will
show a warning message again on the kind
of the landing page once once the user
is logged in then this is a great way to
communicate if you're you know
scheduling maintenance windows or if you
have you know information that you want
to communicate to all of your users this
is a nice way to do that lastly the last
topic I want to cover is the notion of
private packages and so packrat is going
to gracefully handle all the public
packages that you have whether
crayon or bioconductor or even if
they're you know hosted on github or get
lab or anything like that you know these
are all going to work pretty well within
packrat without any customization but
private packages are a bit more
complicated and so when you have a
private package the best way to actually
facilitate this is to use a private
crayon and so if you are able to set up
kind of a private crane instance and we
have documentation it's actually not not
nearly as complicated as it sounds but
basically if you're able to set up a
private grant instance then that that
can just host your private packages and
then what you can do is you can have
your users install those packages from
that private grant instance and now you
know within your firewall you're able to
kind of host your private packages and
then connect would be able to pull from
those or from that private crane
instance to be able to pull those
packages down and install them just like
it does from the public crane instances
so all of this again is documented here
at the link that I provided the advent
guide and it's actually not as
intimidating as it sounds but this is
actually a really nice way just
internally for you to kind of version
and manager on our packages regardless
of the fact that that it would enable
them enable you to access them from the
connected switch as well all right so
that is kind of the the tour of the
things that I wanted to introduce around
our studio konnekt a few additional
resources that will point you to here so
first of all if you haven't tried out
connected you can download them install
a 45 day free trial using this link here
the admin guide is available all the
information that I just covered it is
described and documented in the admin
guide and so the goal of this webinar is
really just to kind of highlight the
specific points that you might want to
consider out of the admin guide but
certainly if you're going to be managing
a production connector very well well
worth your while just can some time
familiarizing yourself with the admin
guide here we do if you're kind of have
an IT bench we do have an IT Q&A page
that's available for for connection I
answer some common questions that we get
from IT folks if you're looking to set
up authentication the authentication
details are available here and lastly we
do have our release notes available
online as well and so if you're
interested in kind of checking out the
differences between particular versions
or seeing what the kind of more detailed
changes that take place every time we
release a version then all of this would
be available at this link here
and so that is everything that I have
and so let me go ahead and just take a
moment and pull up some of our questions
and see if if we have any questions that
might be worth okay so the question is
does our studio konnekt have the
equivalent of an obscured URL anonymous
view-only access like Google Docs share
URL these case I have in mind that so
that we can have external clients
allowing them to view a shiny out posted
under our connect server so this is not
something that we support today
basically everything that we that we do
is around kind of explicit
authentication and so if you want users
to have access to a particular
application then you would have to
explicitly add them to your content and
then they would you know when they log
in they would be able to view that in
your content listing and it would be
kind of fully enumerated for them but
that is an interesting feature request
and that's something that we should
definitely keep in mind yeah so one
question here that you should be aware
around self signing SSL certificates
that I'll point this out here so back in
the HTTP section it is not a problem for
you to sell sign a certificate when you
set up HTTPS and the server basically
any valid certificate in keypair we
would be happy to host for you one thing
that you should be aware of though
around custom certificate authorities is
the fact that while your browsers may be
interested within your organization
while your browsers may be instructed to
trust this custom certificate authority
when you're publishing from the our
Studio IDE that is using a different set
of network connectors than the browser
and so we're usually using Perl or you
know whatever networking systems are
available in your server or on the
desktop if you're using our studio
desktop and so you do need to be aware
that not only do your browsers need to
trust your SSL certificate but also
whatever systems you're using from the
Rs connect package an IDE to publish
content onto the server which is often
curl those also need to be instructed to
trust your custom certificates and so if
you have any custom SSL certificates or
custom CA or an internal CA you do need
to be aware that all of your studio
clients would also need to be instructed
to trust that custom CA can you provide
any
Abell as a functional run a setup
yeah so we definitely if you look into
our documentation we definitely have
some some information some more details
on that and you would see certainly you
know the most trivial application would
be just to customize a hard-coded user
here and you can just define that you
know whatever user in one of our groups
that you want you can just define here
in this custom setting that should be
pretty straightforward kind of these
more advanced specifications around you
know runners current user really just
depend on your environment and so I
guess the reason that we don't have kind
of more details or kind of an example
set up for this is that it really just
depends on what your environment is how
you have you know Kerberos and pan
configured and so a lot of that is just
going to depend on on kind of your
environment but definitely even if
you're doing a trial even if you haven't
purchased a product yet I'd encourage
you to contact support at our studio com
if you're you know encountering any
troubles here or if you want could have
helped in reviewing the architecture or
working with your IT folks to to kind of
provision an environment that's going to
be successful for your connect instance
we'd be happy to work with you but other
than that I think that is about
everything that I was hoping to cover
today so I think we are about go to wine
up
[Music]